he was local what could he sell up about
as the horror unfolded people ran to
safety but Gerald voles did the opposite
he told me how he acted as a decoy and
confronted the terrorists I was going
away wait cowards
and I remember for a bottle I think I
checked to stall pint glasses because I
fall the police are going the wrong way
I could hear him going straight up I
said we're going to we're actually first
thatment but did already left that
saying there was in the market and there
was attacking people now so long as they
follow me and they traced me I can get
into two main road police and I was
shooting dead what I can shoot them or
they can obviously get them on the
ground and get control of the situation
and save people's eyes as the chaos
continued outside many hid in the
basements of bars and restaurants yes
yeah yeah all they could do was wait
wait for the police
to lead them to safety turn right over
night hundreds were evacuated from
hotels in Barra this morning guests were
allowed back with some wearing dressing
gowns as they hadn't had the chance to
gather their belongings when the alarm
was raised the fire alarm went off and
we realized that it was a serious fire
alarm with all this going on so we were
herded downstairs quite quickly what me
and then over the bridge and the
policemen were very anxious for us to
move as quickly as possible they kept
saying go faster go faster they just
want to just get away from the area we
were very well guided so all the time we
had policemen around us telling us where
to go witnesses have described hearing
gunfire stabbings and a van careering
through crowds of people on London
Bridge and you can see behind me the bus
is still parked up there and with this
being the third terror attack in the UK
and as many months understandably many
people are feeling anxious on Twitter
last night help flooded in for those
caught up in the attack good Samaritans
use the hashtag SOPA for London offering
people a place to stay nearby others
expressed gratitude to taxi drivers
who'd given them a
you're discounted fare following the
horror of recent weeks people have
united across the country and here in
London it's no different
Rebecca Williams Sky News